it's the Moment of Truth Now we will
each give our decisions on who has had
the botched surgery I think Destiny had
the truthful medical experience I
believe that it was Edward who has had a
botched surgery based on my regular
knowledge of regular things
I believe it was Brendan who had the
botch to surgery
I personally made the choice of Edward
because I felt that when I asked about
pain I felt that he had more intimate
knowledge I chose to ask indirect
questions I went about it very mundane
the main reason why I picked Brendan was
because Destiny's story seemed so absurd
to me that like a doctor would just pull
out a knife and just slice open
something just like that but I guess
truth is Stranger Than Fiction